[Applause]
welcome back y'all our next guest is a
legendary chef with more than a dozen
restaurants to his name he's also a
best-selling author TV personality and
the founder of world Central Kitchen his
newest book is a graphic novel about
world Central Kitchen called feeding
dangerously let's welcome everybody Chef
Jose
[Applause]
[Music]
Andres
[Applause]
[Music]
yes lay down so we're going to start
with your childhood I'm just kidding I'm
just kidding no I heard wait I love your
energy by the way and I not kidding I'm
bald like getting ready for this
interview cuz you are an amazing human
you're an incredible
you are like it's like it's really
amazing like what you do I knew about
the restaurants I know all that stuff I
didn't know all about the humanitarian
stuff you're an incredible man well as
my wife she may have a different
opinion uh we've been almost 30 years
married and she says that Technically
she's been married to me 60 years I
don't know it feels more it feels like
more yeah as my daughters I don't think
they will have the same opinion of
you
that's okay family is supposed to keep
it real daddy don't speak English nobody
can understand you we will translate for
you this type of
daughters so yeah I guess I'm a good
human being this type of daughters I
likeit so speaking of your daughter you
have a a thing in your your household
like cooking paa is like a very
dangerous thing what and why what yeah
what happened I think this is fake news
people this is something is going around
no I hear it's about fire
okay okay all right I am a that check
that that I'm a cook that I believe my
daughters to be out of Danger's way I
will have them better prepared for life
if I teach them from early on about the
dangers of the world not putting them
behind walls so yes I let my daughters
use knives with barely they were two
years old and cook with open and fire
and sometimes the fires I make a home
they can be very big cooking the p and
my and the fire is bigger than my
daughter's and the fire is a really big
fire and when you have little daughters
and big fire and you're teaching your
daughters how to make the paa the fire
sometimes is nice the the fire wants to
help you wants to kiss you because fire
is a good person if you treat it with
respect and I think the fire B used to
give kind of a little kiss to my
daughter's
eyebrows and and was a little you know
smelly little bit my daughters were
overdoing it Daddy you Barn me I didn't
Barn you who's the fire who's the fire I
said don't tell anything to Mommy please
don't just let's keep it I mean yeah
when I forgot one of my daughters yeah
in the supermarket but I came back
I hey but I came back
hey I I I didn't had salt and was very
important I was baking a fish in salt
and my daughter yeah you got the salt
but what about me so yeah but between
the fire and that I I don't think in
here yeah yeah
fire oh my gosh that looked cool too the
thing you were cooking it in that was
really cool we showed the video of that
big black thing that was cool AA pen
that is what no but what's the thing
underneath of it was it connected yeah
it's like is I look I'm going to be real
with you I make like nothing so like I'm
not a cook so I've never seen yeah yeah
no you're not a cook no and I am it's
not fair you don't you don't sing when
you cook no yeah that's I got the one
Talent man yeah that's it still I don't
think she has one tal I think she has
many many tal I can't even make eggs I
can't make eggs people of America the
Kelly and Jose cooking show yeah she
teach me I'm she teaches me to sing and
I teach her to
goo as long as no one okay I'll do that
as long as no one's eating my food no
wait but speaking of food like my this
is a good segue my dogs will not even
eat my food so you have you have made a
pet food which would they would love so
it's called Ra Mesa man your
pronunciation is unbelievable unbel real
okay so yeah I have this I got this line
that uh us we put out of amazing dog
food um when I was young uh my father my
mother we had a home a German Shepherd
my father will cook for us and we cook
for the dog I think he put more love in
cooking for the dog he did for us and I
was with friends they have a lot of
experiencing the bed business and they
Jose why you don't do use a pet food
that celebrate your yeah Latino Spanish
heritance and I thought was
a great idea because when you're eaing
with friends good ideas always come and
then I realize that even in the worst
moments of
humanity um people sometimes will put
themselves in dangers I've seen it in
Ukraine I've seen it in so many other
parts that a pet in a way is as part of
the family and will be people not living
in their homes even if sometimes it's
not as smart because they can't be in
danger but for them if they cannot take
the dogs with them they will stay next
to them so this is this 160° story of
yes everybody is family even our pets
are family so it's great that uh real
Mesa a percentage of the profits uh that
hopefully be successful and we'll have
profits are always going to go in this
case to support my NGO W Centra kitchen
that this is a way that if you take care
of every family you know the families
are also taking care of their pets yeah
I want to talk about world Central
Kitchen this is it had me just balling
learning all this about you this is at
the most devastating moments in people's
lives you come in and you feed these
people don't nobody even really thinks
about that I don't think that's not the
first thing at the Forefront of their
mind so what got you into this
well what got me into this is to
understand that sometimes in emergencies
food and water was an
afterthought and that cooks like me that
we feed the few we had the same power to
feed the many mhm and especially we all
come together his restaurants everywhere
every Arena has food stands his food
tracks his catering companies and I
thought oh my God I watched
Katrina how we had tens of thousands of
Americans almost forgotten in the Super
Dome where actually it was very easy to
take care of them for days they didn't
receive food and water so I thought what
if so I didn't do anything in the Trina
I stay in the comfort of my home when ha
happened 2010 I took a plan the big
earthquake that killed hundreds of
thousands of Asians in poor Prince I
went and I began doing what I know
learning and I began feeding people
without realizing we been now in every
single Hurricane earthquake volcano and
lately also in conflict in Ukraine alone
in the last two years we've done more
than 240 million meals inside
Ukraine uh unfortunately right now we're
we in Armenia we're in Lebanon uh we are
in Israel uh doing more than 240,000
hand meals already we are also inside
gasa 240,000 meals also hot and a
million meals so people can cook
themselves because we already had food
inside Gaza at the end what we are
trying to send a message is that food
and water is a universal human right we
believe in longer tables and bringing
people together
yeah it's it's also the the beauty of it
is obviously we need food and water but
the beauty of it too is that they're
you're not forgotten like people are not
forgetting you like to have the impact
of that of them walking up and
everything is just their life has been
devastated and somebody cooking a warm
meal for them that's that's transforms
Hearts it's such an important message
because people don't want our pity they
want our respect what w dran does is CS
but we allow every single local that
wants to help and volunteer
to join us it's not like we make them
better they make us better because who
is better than the locals that know
their communities that's why in the case
of Ukraine we went from two people of
all Centra kitchen to a team of more
than 550 restaurants and 5,000 team
members Distributing food all across
Ukraine you see the domino effect we
built teams everybody wants to help in
the worst moments of humanity the best
of humanity shows up I agree with that
well I want to talk about this because
you have a new graphic novel it's
feeding dangerously so I didn't I didn't
know this about you but you're like
really into Like Comics graphic novels
all that right manga I I love you look
10 years old right now
look yeah I love it I love it so this is
important to you so you know the amazing
social media that you receive now
messages and you can talk to everybody
is Steve Orlando I mean Steve Orlando is
like the the libron James Jordan Messi
of of comic books and he text me like
hey
dude I want to tell the story of w Andra
kitchen I'm like okay cool and here we
are four five years later which tells
the story of the beginnings of WRA but
there you're going to see stories of the
many men and women that did the
incredible uh happen under very
difficult circumstances so you're going
to see me cooking PA with my dad because
he was a very important early influence
you're going to see us then cooking PA
in the middle of Puerto Rico when we fed
4 million people after Maria uh Category
5 Hurrican destroy the entire Island
you're going to see many of the key
moments that made wsen dritan what it is
today we are still learning we're still
a very young organization but with this
book with this comic uh I want to tell
the story of what we're doing so more
people can join us more people can be
empowered to do what what we do and then
one day we can say we'll never have
hunger again ever in the world if we
come together we can solve the big
problems that Humanity facing this is a
fun way to tell that story yeah a very
cool way to do it I'm going to hold it
up cuz I love it it's so people are so
talented like it's incredible to me but
everybody for more details on world
Central Kitchen check out our Instagram
story all right we are back and I'm
hanging out with Chef Jose andrez and
our next guest
are super stoked to meet him in fact he
is the actual inspiration behind their
efforts to keep people in their
Community fed they've rallied fellow
high schoolers to come together to start
a program similar to World Central
Kitchen on a local level from kitchens
for change everybody say hello to Elias
and
Audrey so meet chef
Jose so okay I'm gonna ask youall like
explain kitchens for change where did
this come from and the inspiration at
its core kitchen for change is really
about uh high schoolers coming together
and trying to combat the issue of food
insecurity in our local community and
really we found our the it's the legs
for this organization um it was me and
my mother we're sitting there and we saw
you know post pandemic how rampant the
issue of food insecurity was in our
local community and we had seen uh Jose
Andreas and the amazing work he did with
World Central Kitchen and we thought to
ourselves you know we can do a spin-off
of this in our local community and
really make a great impact yeah and both
Elias and I's families are in the
restaurant business so we got to
thinking how can we use the resources we
have with our restaurants to get
students involved in tackling food
insecurities within our community and to
our surprise we had over a hundred
students willing to jump on board with
our mission yeah so we used our
restaurants kitchens after hours to get
students in there mentored by local
chefs and we started cooking for areas
in our community that were facing food
insecurity and to this day we're not
just a club on campus but we're an
actual nonprofit organization with
multiple chapors that's so
incredible so what have you learned like
because I love one thing you said you
said your organization like we still
have more to learn and I think any
organization that knows that is the
organization to get behind because to
stop learning is death I think of
anything you know of a human of an
organization or whatnot so what what do
you think that you learned through World
cental kitchen what I learn is that very
often uh we are taught that we always
need to follow a plan what did we learn
during the pandemic that very often
things never go as plan what happens if
you embrace the complexity of the moment
and you train your family your your
businesses the people around you to
adapt adaptation wins the day over
planning what these two amazing
individuals they've done they adapted to
the situation they saw what they had
around them and they did the most they
could with what was at their disposal to
use their family businesses restaurants
uh after hours used to Feit the local
community need is used a magical simple
powerful idea these people like them
that yes we can change America we can
improve America we can change the world
absolutely absolutely I that well
Elias's mama moini is in the audience
and she's a culinary teacher at his high
school and helps advise kitchens for
change so moini oh my gosh I mean you've
got to be so proud yes I am um I am so
proud of Audrey and Elias um ever since
Elias was born I as a gut level as a mom
I knew he was destined for something
great and I think they both are and
whatever they do in their life I just
want them to always remember this time
in their life and that passion and what
food means for people and that's where
you hit the core and Chef Jose Andreas
you are an epitome of success for
students for chefs for People Like Us
you've taken something and you've given
back to this world um and it's
everything that's good about this world
thank you you're the
best and she gave me amazing Indian
spices oh she did I cannot wait to get
to my kitchen and start cooking with
those um well our friends this is for
Elias and Audrey our friends at ConAgra
believe everybody deserves consistent
access to nutritious food and they love
the work that you're doing at kitchens
for change so they are donating $10,000
to help
out yes incredible absolutely thank you
so much absolutely thank you all so much
for joining us we're going to be right
back
everybody
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you guys y'all have a great night
I'm going
home